[Applause]
I listen we cannot start until the Press
moves back three feet now I know that
you want to hear har vilda speak I know
I want to hear her vilda speak so we
cannot start until the Press moves back
three feet so let's encourage the press
to move back three fre okay let's hear
it let's go come on guys start
moving you have to move back rep feet it
has to happen thank
you God bless you I am Pamela Geller and
I want to thank
you I want to thank you all for coming
before we begin today's program let us
pause let us stop and remember those
that fell on this day stop stop
screaming let us stop and remember those
who fell on this day we're going to
pause we will never forget the victims
we will never
forget stop stop stop yelling we will
never forget the children 800 children
that lost a parent we will never forget
the heroic the the heroic actions of
those that responded to to those in need
we will
prevail and now a moment of silence
[Music]
God Bless America that was Tom
Butterfield whose great-grandfather
actually wrote
Taps and now I'll introduce
you can you
see by the
[Music]
what at the
Twilight
Lings broad stripes and bright
stars through the
per fight all the
ramps we
watch were so
gently stre
[Music]
and The
Rock the bombs
bur gave Pro through the
night that our flag was still
there that star
[Music]
Spangles yet
for the
land of the
[Music]
free and the
home of the
[Music]
[Applause]
God and Country we're going to begin now
with
prayers for those who suffered losses on
911 and for all of us as a nation please
welcome
three clergymen who are with us today
Father Christopher manwell is a priest
of the melite Greek Catholic Church
which is a church based mainly in the
Middle East many Christian Arabs one of
the religious groups most subject to
jihadist persecution around the world
Rabbi Steven axelman who is a trained
psychotherapist and a talmudic scholar
who runs a congregation in the New York
City area and Dr Jim garlo a pastor Who
was appointed by former house Speaker
new Gingrich to be the chairman of a
group called renewing American
leadership based in
Washington in the name of the father and
of the son and of the holy spirit amen
oh Christ Our God you said when I am
lifted up from the earth on that
lifegiving wood of the cross I will draw
all men to
myself look look graciously upon the
servants and handmaidens who have
perished here and elsewhere in The
Crucible of
9/11 have mercy on them show their faith
to be a faith that works through love
and their Good Deeds to be the Splendor
of their glory and make them to be sons
of God and HS to your Eternal
promises oh Christ Our God as you w on
the precious cross in the unfathomable
depth of your compassion you
said I
thirst thirsting for our love send down
upon your servants and
handmaids the promise of the Holy Spirit
on those gathered here to pray for and
to honor their loved
ones grant them the fire of your Divine
love so that we might follow your
example and obey your
Commandments oh Christ Our God as you
breathed your last breath as man
crucified between two thieves you cried
out to your heavenly father into your
hands father I commend my
spirit we likewise commend ourselves and
our Nations to you oh God our heavenly
father for by the shedding of your son's
Divine blood we have made our for peace
with you save O Lord your people and
bless your inheritance preserve our
nation in peace Deliver Us from the
hands of our visible and invisible
enemies confirm in your truth and Grace
our government our Civil Authorities and
all those who protect us that in their
Tranquility we may lead a calm and quiet
life in all virtue and
honor oh Christ Our God God Seated on
the throne of your glory you said to
your beloved disciple behold your mother
and to your mother you said woman behold
your
son and from that hour your mother took
us to her own o lady Theos Mary the ever
virgin do not forsake us in our time of
Affliction be our prompt intercessor For
unto you this great land of America has
been entrusted under your title of she
who is without
sin for you oh Christ Our God have
dominion over the living and the dead
you are the lover of mankind and in your
name all nations shall be blessed and so
we render glory honor and adoration to
you the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit both now and ever and unto the
ages of Ages amen amen May their memory
be
Eternal this
[Music]
day in sacred
convocation we remember those whose
lives were taken in a brutal murderous
attack against civilians going about
their daily
lives we remember those First
Responders police officers firemen and
others who made the ultimate
sacrifice attempting to save the lives
of those Trapped In The
Inferno exalted compassionate God God of
Abraham Isaac and Jacob Grant perfect
peace in your shelter Al in presence
among the holy and pure to The Souls of
all those men women and children who
perished on September 11th
2001 or as a result of the events of
that dark
Day May their memories abide among us as
a lasting
benediction inspiring us all to live
courageously and
unselfishly in peace and harmony with
all our fellow men may their souls be
bound up in the bond of life may they
rest in peace together with the
righteous of all Nations and all history
and let us say
Amen almighty God master of Mercy healer
of the
Brokenhearted be gracious to your
children who
mourn may they always cherish what was
imperishable in the lives of their loved
ones may the light of your presence
dispel the Gloom of
absence that is so keenly felt on this
sad day bless them with your
compassion Empower them with your love
touch them with the fullness of your
heart that they may be granted inner
peace and let us say
amen and finally as the Jews pray
several times daily
shom
shom may he who makes peace in his high
places may he make peace for us and for
all mankind and let us say
Amen Our God and our father thank you
for being both our God and our father we
need you we need you at all times every
day but especially when we're at this
sight on this day we're reminded of the
depth of our need for you I join with my
brothers my friends who prayed before me
for those who have lost loved ones for
that man who's lost a wife we lift him
to you right now for that woman who's
lost a husband for those children who
are without a mommy and a daddy today
for parents who've lost sons and
daughters and many who've lost friends
we lift up those who are hurting on this
day and father I ask for the miraculous
that somehow on this day of deep pain
and this day of remembrance that can
cause such trauma I pray for comfort to
flow into Hearts I pray for Supernatural
Comfort to flow into hearts and do what
only you can do in this healing day ABA
father may we figuratively sit on your
lap and have your arms around us on this
day as healing moves into those
so many who've lost loved ones on this
site our words cannot declare this
ground hallowed it's hallowed by those
who've lost their lives here but we add
to the thousands of voices who've
declared this a special place a special
place marking our memories as a nation
and we pray that it'll always be
regarded in a sacred hallowed way that
no desecration could ever take place of
this sight we ask for a shield of
protection over you now in this meeting
a shield of protection over over you on
this sight a shield of protection over
this city and over our great land we
pray in the name of Jesus Amen